what's up everyone there are a lot of
theories going around about avengers'
for right now all of which of course
involve
time travel and today's theory we'll
talk about time travel as well but not
in the way you think and now it's here
what should I say if you're new to my
channel I'm doing a special giveaway
right now I'm giving away a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia as well
the winner gets all three if you'd like
to enter all I have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so we've been talking
about all of these Avengers 4 theories
that all have to do with time-travel
being sort of the main plot but what if
we're wrong what if Avengers 4 is just
about our original Avengers who are all
the Avengers that are left at the end of
infinity war taking on Thanos once again
this time defeating him gaining control
over the Infinity Gauntlet and undoing
Thanos a snap however likely or unlikely
it is not too many people have just
stopped and thought about this what sort
of confirmation have we really gotten
that there will be time travel in
Avengers 4 I think the closest thing
that we've gotten to a confirmation is
Kevin Feige telling us that Ant Man and
the wasp connect directly to Avengers 4
but it didn't connect that much to
Avengers 4 it really the only thing that
really happened was at the end Hank
Janet and hope all turned to dust but
Janet very quickly mentioned a time
vortex which is what we all think will
connect ant-man and the wasp to Avengers
4 but again no actual confirmation we do
have leaked photos that definitely look
like the Avengers are going back in time
however this could all just be Tony
Stark's barf technology perhaps they are
trying to revisit some events from the
past to learn more about Thanos and his
army that's how we should happen
now it seems like there has to be at
least one person that time travels in
Avengers 4 and that is ant-man but maybe
he just comes out in a different
timeline and that's it no doubt they
would try to discover time-travel but
maybe they don't maybe he comes out into
the future somewhere which is why we see
tony stark looking so much older and if
he comes out in the future the snap
isn't undone which means hank
jana and hope are all dust
[Music]
guys
okay seriously don't joke hurry up bring
me up let's go
then there's dr. strange many people
believe that in the one scenario that
dr. strange saw were the Avengers defeat
Thanos dr. strange had to be a victim of
the snap
why so he could go to Soul world it is
unclear whether Adam warlock will appear
in Avengers 4 or not but it does seem
like Doctor Strange could possibly play
a little bit of Adam warlocks role from
the comics in the comics Adam warlock
can escape the soul world and he's even
helped others escape using a spell
perhaps that's why Doctor Strange needed
to be a victim of the snap so he could
go to Soul world and help all the other
fallen heroes escape this could very
well have him because in the Infinity
Gauntlet series Adam warlock escapes and
then he wields the Infinity Gauntlet
it's also been said that nebula will
play a huge role in Avengers 4 as well
and in the Infinity Gauntlet series she
wields the Infinity Gauntlet as well so
maybe Avengers 4 it won't be so much
about time travel but really be about
the Avengers coming together
kicking Thanos his butt and takin the
Infinity Gauntlet in which they would
then undo Thanos to snap
[Music]
so the question is are the Russo
brothers sort of trolling us a little
bit intentionally leaking these photos
to make it seem like Avengers four will
be time travel I wouldn't put it past
them seeing how hard they told us for
Avengers infinity war obviously their
goal was to try and keep Avengers
infinity war as secretive and surprising
as possible in which they did a really
good job at and the researchers have
come out and said and that's really the
whole idea behind this theory is we have
no idea what Avengers 4 is really going
to be about so if we are all talking
time-travel and then the Russo brothers
come out and say you have no idea what
this movie's going to be about is it
really going to have time travel that
remains to be seen I however do think
that there's a lot of evidence that says
we are going to have some time travel in
Avengers 4 and in fact it'll be a major
part of Avengers 4 it just seems like
there is a lot of evidence pointing
towards time travel and Avengers 4 but
then again and the whole point of this
theory is the Russo brothers said we
have no idea what the movie is going to
be about so what do you all think about
this do you think that there's enough
evidence to support the fact that time
travel will be a big part of Avengers 4
or do you think that time travel isn't
going to be that involved and the Russo
brothers are telling the truth when they
say we have no idea what Avengers 4 it
will actually be about let me know what
you all think in the comments below and
again don't forget about the giveaway
I'm doing I'm giving away a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray a
special poster and some special
memorabilia all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you